let's talk about the Nile River and why
Egypt and Ethiopia have been fighting
over it the problem is this dam being
built in Ethiopia once it's finished
it'll be the most powerful hydroelectric
dam in Africa each other's knowledge
systems are not militarily but Egypt
says its supply of water is in danger of
drying up hoodlum methanol a horror
about [ __ ]
after years of talks they're now saying
they're close to signing a deal on how
to share the water but there are lots of
details that need to be worked out so
why has it been so hard to end the
battle for the Nile its official name is
the ground
Ethiopian Renaissance dam and it's huge
when they're done building it the
reservoir will be bigger than Greater
London and cover almost 1,700 square
kilometres the largest project the
government has ever embarked upon the
original cost of it was around and
significantly more than that but before
we get into the dispute about the dam
itself it helps to understand the now
basin and what's at stake 11 African
countries are in it and 280 million
people live there the Nile is also fun
fact the only major river that runs
south to north one of the rivers
tributaries the Blue Nile starts off in
Lake Tana in Ethiopia and converges with
the White Nile incidence capital
Khartoum
from there the Nile flows downstream to
Egypt there are several dams along the
way including Egypt's Aswan down the
Ethiopia is building its power plant
upstream right here on the border with
Sadat now as the name Renaissance
suggests this dam is supposed to revive
Ethiopia's economy it'll provide
electricity to millions of Ethiopians
and that's big because right now more
than two-thirds of the population aren't
connected to the grid that's about 75
million people over several years it
will produce 6,000 megawatts
Ethiopia's current generating capacity
is only 4,000
so this dam is also going to generate
more power for Ethiopia than it needs
meaning it can export electricity that's
all very good news for Ethiopia but if
you ask a [ __ ] this dam will be
catastrophic
the null has been at the center of
Egyptian life for millennia an entire
ancient civilization was built around it
and relied on the river for transport
and irrigation and that's still the case
today the country relies on the Nile for
almost all of its water it's a rain
starved largely desert country so
obviously any potential interruptions
the flow of the Nile is justifiably a
huge concern for Egypt Egypt controls
most of the flow of the River Nile into
its country at least for now
Egypt's biggest worry is how quickly
Ethiopia will fill the reservoir and our
colleagues at al-jazeera labs have
studied a few scenarios say Ethiopia
agrees to fill the reservoir over the
next 10 years AG labs says that would
cut Egypt's water supply and by 14% and
destroy 18 percent of its farmland if he
Theo Pia fills the dam more quickly say
over seven years one-third of Egypt's
farmland would be lost and a five year
window would destroy half of that land
according to their simulations this is
how the Egyptian Delta would change over
those ten years so Ethiopia is best-case
scenario filling the dam as soon as
possible is Egypt's worst nightmare it's
no wonder these negotiations have been
tough
it was during the Arab Spring in 2011
while Egypt had a revolution on its
hands that Ethiopia started building the
dam
ever since then Egyptian leaders have
tried to stop the project and military
conflict never seemed far last year
Ethiopia accused Egypt of sending rebels
to neighboring Eritrea to sabotage the
dam prompting another knowledge-sharing
country Sudan to send its troops to its
border in 2018 the operating manager of
the Ethiopian damson men yuba Kelly was
found dead Bacolod sudden death drew
crowds and raised suspicions it was
reported he'd been shot in broad
daylight which led to protests but in
the end the authorities said bakkali
took his own life in 2019 Ethiopia's
Prime Minister avi Ahmed even said no
force could stop Ethiopia from building
a dam if there's a need to go to war we
could get millions readied if some could
fire a missile others could use bombs
this is ultimately an age-old debate
about who owns the Nile in 1929 Egypt
signed a treaty with Britain a colonial
power in Africa at the time that
basically guarantees its access to the
Nile and gave Egypt a veto over
construction projects on the river but
Ethiopia didn't sign that treaty then in
1999 all the Nile Basin countries
including Egypt and Ethiopia signed an
agreement on managing water but that
deal was compromised in 2010 when six of
those countries decided to draw up
another treaty this time Egypt rejected
it because it threatened its historic
rights to water Egypt's concern that if
it moves into new treaty governing the
Nile Basin then it will be left short of
water resources and also its control
over the situation will be massively
reduced and as far as sedan goes it's
sort of caught in the middle Egypt is
sedan's political ally but the
government supports the Renaissance down
because it'll be a source of affordable
energy and it will help regulate
flooding when Eliezer it was that Matata
get them magma rattle Tejada whe lo the
good news is that Egypt Ethiopia and
Sudan
are in talks with one another the bad
news is that they still haven't answered
the tough questions questions like when
there's a drought will Ethiopia consider
Egypt's needs and when is a drought a
drought those conversations will only
get tougher because more dams are being
planned populations are growing and the
climate is changing all of which will
make the Nile and the supply of water
increasingly worth fighting over
hope your findings start here useful the
idea is that we lay out the basics and
bring you up to speed with what's going
on in the news but as always
aljazeera.com and all our social media
pages have all the latest updates I'll
see you next week
you
[Music]